una ley con más de 50 años y que ha
servido para el crecimiento de disney
podría desaparecer y es que la mayoría
de la cámara de representantes del
estado de florida aprobó un proyecto de
ley para la eliminación del distrito
especial fiscal donde se establece la
empresa de entretenimiento ellos desde
la creación de disney abre en 1971 ellos
tienen este estatus desde 1967 antes de
abrirse el parque han tenido control de
cómo se desarrolla la zona puede tener
cierto impacto en disney desde el punto
de vista de que ellos pierden el control
desde esa zona estamos hablando que en
la zona que comprende el parque son más
de 100 kilómetros cuadrados y está entre
dos diferentes distritos de la florida
la disputa entre el gobernador ron de
santis y disney se produce luego de que
la compañía de entretenimiento planteara
su oposición a la ley que prohíbe hablar
sobre orientación sexual y diversidad de
género en las escuelas primarias del
estado conocida como no digas que desde
la casa blanca rechazan la posición del
gobernador
nos oponemos a que el gobernador toma
medidas contra una empresa porque se
opone a este proyecto de ley de la
medida tendría serias implicaciones para
la empresa que recibe unos 50 millones
de visitantes al año recauda unos 5 mil
millones anuales en ingresos fiscales
locales y estatales y genera unos 80 mil
empleos
la iniciativa que espera por la firma de
de santis podría entrar en vigor para
junio de 2023 y se suma a una serie de
posiciones polémicas del gobernador en
torno al racismo la ideología de género
y la lucha contra el kobe 19 que le han
permitido ganar popularidad entre los
republicanos